you know you can't buy real estate but
he's saying you can't take a loan on it
because you pay interest with loans but
that's like some of the basic
Ally exactly you have to take a loan
unless he's basically telling you you
got to buy houses cash because that way
you don't have interest but it's very
difficult to buy houses cash and it's
not intelligent
I can't even invest my money yeah no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no When You observe this
again just coming from the young people
perspective when they talk about metrics
right this is exactly it wow that's been
programmed good point that's a solid
point and so him saying that you can't
get rich unless you take a loan how do
people make money how do people buy
property in fact how did Elon Musk
become the richest person in the world
it's not true that it's actually
completely opposite way he invented
something people invested through equity
and this is even today the fastest way
that people make money